el primer ministro boris johnson
presentó en el parlamento un
controvertido proyecto de ley que anula
de manera unilateral lo que ella había
pactado en la ley de retirada con la
unión europea el premier británico
defendió la ley del mercado interno que
según él va a garantizar el mercado
entre el reino unido- principalmente con
la provincia de irlanda del norte que ha
sido uno de los puntos más álgidos en la
salida del reino unido- de la unión
europea
los críticos de johnson pero también
ministros de su propio partido
conservador han criticado esta medida ya
que aseguran viola la ley internacional
la presidenta de la comisión europea
úrsula van der leyen manifestó su
preocupación sobre esta nueva maniobra
política y aseguró que además de violar
la ley internacional pone en riesgo la
futura relación comercial entre el reino
unido y la unión europea la maniobra
política sucede en
de una nueva ronda de negociaciones aquí
en londres sobre un acuerdo de libre
comercio que entraría en vigor una vez
que el reino unido- abandone el bloque
de naciones el próximo 31 de diciembre